christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur découvrir hier les résultats
de la campagne d'évaluation qui a été
menée de septembre à décembre 2019 sur
un panel de sites sont victimes de
violences sexuelles et sexistes pour
près de 90% des victimes
il n'y a pas de difficultés pour
enregistrer une plainte déjà le premier
grand combat c'est celui de la
libération de la parole nous avons
aujourd'hui une augmentation des
plaintes sur les violences
intrafamiliales et c'est une bonne
nouvelle certains jouent à commenter ces
statistiques en disant envoyés la
situation va mal non une chose est sûre
c'est que je ne considérerai jamais
qu'une femme qui franchit la porte d'un
commissariat d'une jeune maman ils
portent porter plainte c'est un problème
statistiques c'est un problème de
sécurité de sûreté que nous devons
garantir et chaque femme qui
franchissait tu portes la doit être
protégé mieux encore selon les audits
réalisés dans les commissariats et
brigades de gendarmerie plus de 75% des
victimes trouvent que la confidentialité
des locaux est satisfaisante pour la
gendarmerie l'objectif est qu une femme
victime de violences déposent plainte
dans un premier temps au lidl parce que
généralement elles sont assez gêné la
situation s'est déjà très compliqué pour
elle de passer la porte de la
gendarmerie
donc si en plus elle devait être dans un
milieu ouvert ou reçoit où il ya des
va-et-vient que ce soit des gendarmes de
deux personnes civiles ça peut être
assez gênant pour elles mêmes elles
seront fermées au contraire
au lieu de nous donner toutes les
informations les tout garder pour elle
et se renfermer sur elle même en disant
mais peut-être qu'en fait c'était pas la
bonne solution je n'aurais pas dû venir
et regretter son son acte alors qu'en
fait c'est un très grand pas quel est
son caleçon et nous
voilà on lit on les isole et ensuite on
prend au cas par cas on a beau être
formées chaque victime est différente
suite à la présentation du travail des
enquêteurs le ministre de l'intérieur
tire un bilan positif n'est pas encore
pleinement satisfaisant je veux aussi
d'ailleurs que nous affirmions encore le
questionnaire pour une évaluation plus
rigoureuse plus précise encore de
l'accueil dans nos commissariats et dans
nos gendarmerie christophe castaner
s'est rendu par la suite à l'hôpital
mignot pour signer une convention dans
les établissements de santé en vue
d'améliorer la prise en charge des
plaintes des victimes de violences
conjugales
quant à l'audit il se poursuivra durant
l'année 2020